Let's look at the solution to our
global and local miss rate quiz.
For our Level 1 cash, when we say that
it has a 90% hit rate, we don't have
to specify whether it's a global or
local hit rate because it's the same.
Its local miss rate is
the number of misses divided by
the number of accesses to this cache.
Its global miss rate is the number of
misses divided by all the accesses that
the processor makes, but because all
these accesses go to this cache,
they are the same and they are both 10%.
because that's what percentage
of all processor accesses
misses in this cache, and
that is also the percentage of things
that reach this cache, that miss in it.
For the Level 2 cache,
things are different.
It hits for 50% of L1 misses.
That means that it misses for
half of the L1 misses.
So its local miss rate is 50%.
Of all the things that reach this cache,
and
those are only L1 misses,
half of them hit and half of them miss.
But its global miss rate is only 5%,
because only 10% of
the accesses get to this cache,
and half of that misses.
So when we express the misses in terms
of all the accesses that the processor
made, only 5% of all processor accesses
end up missing in the L2 Cache.